[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages then as they arrive time to
see what's making the headlines with the
columnist and broadcaster steve richards
and the director of communications at
the institute of economic affairs
annable then welcome and great to see
both of you and plenty to discuss so
let's take a look at the front pages
then the guardian leading on the
resignations at number 10 after four of
boris johnson's key aides left their
posts
meltdown in downing street is on the
front of the mail which says the
departure of manira merza left the prime
minister in shock
with the chancellor and the bank of
england setting up measures to tackle
the cost of living crisis the financial
times reports that disposable incomes in
the uk are at their tightest in 30 years
the metro calls the announcement of
those plans and the fiscal strife many
people are facing a perfect storm
while the telegraph dubs it the big
squeeze with energy bills set to rise by
almost 700 pounds from april
the express meanwhile wants that
everyone will have to tighten their
belts
ouch says the sun as household bills are
set to soar and after those downing
street resignations
daily mirror accuses cabinet ministers
of laughing as the country braces for
the worst squeezing living standards in
30 years while the northern echo speaks
to a woman from darlington who says
she's forced to choose between buying
food and heating her home calling it
crisis point
so let's bring in then steve richards
and annabelle denim and welcome to both
of you and steve it's amazing isn't it
how quickly the
agenda moves on the biggest squeeze in
living standards as we saw in those
front pages in uh in 30-plus years all
shunted off the front pages by what the
the daily mail is calling um meltdown in
downing street
yeah and in some front pages combine the
two but that's of no comfort to boris
johnson uh the combination of the two
makes for even more nightmarish
headlines these are terrible headlines
for him even in normally sympathetic uh
newspapers as we see from the uh daily
mail there and it has a fander seacla
air to it it's not at all clear to me
that if downing street wanted a party
tonight there would be enough people
there to attend because all these big
figures have left three of them because
of the
nightmare of partygate for them and
they're
involvements or alleged involvements in
them uh but the the most significant is
the departure of his senior advisor on
policy minera merza who uh has known him
best of the quartet by a long way and
has been publicly critical in issuing a
result leaking her resignation letter to
uh the spectator this afternoon and
making clear she was going because of uh
johnson's uh allegations about jimmy
savile in relation uh to kirsten which
one true and he hasn't apologized for so
the combination is it is really dark
but there's one missing element
for a prime minister to fall we know
from previous tottering tory prime
ministers it needs elected politicians
the cabinet to make a move and although
rishi sunak has hinted today he's in a
different place that's not enough well
he's in a different place uh with
regards to raising kierstama in the same
breath as jimmy savile with regard to
the comment being honest i wouldn't have
said it and i'm glad that the prime
minister clarified what he meant now you
know whether that's a great
schism who knows
um but certainly you said that they've
been able to attend these parties nobody
to organize them possibly martin
reynolds one of those to go he if you're
bringing your own bottle fame
alleged fame uh the mail pointing out
that he's he's been dubbed party marty
after that as the alleged organizer of
the notorious bring your own booze party
in the number 10 garden uh the guardian
also with this picturing as you say
manira merza who's been with him since
city hall days and this seems to have
brought forward um the resignations if
that's what they were of these three
other aides jack doyle number 10's
director of communications dan
rosenfield pm's chief of staff and
martin reynolds principal private
secretary as as aforementioned um and uh
you know get all the bad news out in in
one day is that is that something you
would do in your in your job do you
think
sorry if that's to me that was this is
not a coordinated plan by number 10 i
can assure you of that you wouldn't plan
to trigger the headlines they're going
to get tomorrow morning it's um
it it's chaos and they say it has a van
der siekler air but it's complicated uh
rishi sunak as you say has indicated
distance over the savile slur but is he
going to follow that up he'd have
thought deeply about his form of words
about that i remember covering as you
will remember when david miliband was
foreign secretary hinting at differences
with gordon brown but he never followed
them through
and so
different cabinet ministers will have to
calculate what to do but they are the
key
when thatcher fell it wasn't the first
ballot which removed her of tory mps in
1990 she vowed to carry on it was when
cabinet ministers said she had to go
that she went so they must calculate
whether they are being tarnished almost
politically fatally by their continued
support and their contortions to support
boris johnson
um or not
but while they're backing him and while
there isn't this vote of confidence
amongst conservative mps he can survive
this i mean theresa may had a relatively
calm number 10 and she didn't survive
and others have had relatively calm
number tens and didn't survive so that's
not the key it's the cabinet and the
parliamentary party that's the key to
his future
steve that was brilliant but it was
meant for annabelle i do apologize
annabelle as a director i'm sorry
i should have come in yeah
i i mean i agree with steve i don't
think that there was anything
coordinated about this boris johnson
very much seems like a man who has
nowhere left to run
these um
this exodus for number 10 was planned
for next week but i think ramirez
manera's sudden departure has has
hastened it and like steve says this is
extremely damaging for him she was
johnson's close ally for 15 years he
said that she was one of five women who
had uh influenced him it's it's a huge
blow possibly a clue degra and it's made
worse by the fact that she's protesting
his jimmy samuel savile comment against
keith's dharma she said there was no
fair reasonable basis for the prime
minister to have made those accusations
it was not the usual cut and thrust of
politics it was a partisan reference to
a horrendous case of child sex abuse i
think she's absolutely right and i
suspect that boris johnson thought that
he could both avoid and
an apology and uh this story escalating
and her departure on these grounds has
has made that very difficult for him yes
a fantasier coup de grace
you know you're both at it the question
is whether it will be uh the daily
telegraph suggesting um that speculation
is growing in fact that the prime
minister could struggle to fill
the vacant jobs uh the daily telegraph
revealed this week that uh antonio romeo
one of britain's most senior female
civil servants had decided against
applying for the newly created permanent
secretary role at number 10. simon clark
chief secretary to the treasury i think
the last days of rome was more fun um
you know are we seeing a long drawn
drawn-out goodbye
or just you know somebody who can who
can hang on if you're suggesting the
cabinet you know won't bring in the
guillotine
that's the key and conservative mps i
mean newspapers can
form a judgment even normally
sympathetic ones
we can on this program um but the people
with agency are mps and say crucially
the cabinet now it's getting harder for
the cabinet rishi soon i could say
indicated distance over the savile slur
today each morning they have to come on
and defend that slur and other
contortions and when you have his
closest advisor in number 10 in terms of
who he knew best leaving citing that as
a reason for having enough it's going to
be hard for whoever does the morning
round of interviews tomorrow uh you know
the minister to defend it and the harder
it becomes maybe someone will make their
move or enough tory mps will but that's
the key
uh the rest of it he can manage just it
will be empty in number 10 tonight and
it will be chaotic as he feels he's
already filled the policy post with with
ridiculous speed actually
um
but that is manageable it's the minds of
the tory mps that we have to get into to
decide whether this is fatal or not
well the sun is uh pointing out that um
you know he is in the midst of a
political crisis partygate bloodbath as
it puts it as four boris aids out um but
also an economic crisis as well which is
what we will head to now um and uh to
the big squeeze we go that's how the
daily telegraph has built it or to the
metro the perfect storm um however you
dress it up annabelle the squeeze on
living standards and the cost of living
um is not looking pretty for the year
ahead
no not at all and i think we talk a lot
in politics about cut through and i've
always suspected that partygate would
pale in comparison in the damage that it
can do to boris johnson and this
government uh to the cost of living
crisis and now that it's here i think we
can be and no doubt that it's going to
resonate with voters whatever they might
have made of the culture of drinking in
number 10. the figures are absolutely
stark uh households facing the worst
squeeze on their disposable incomes for
at least three decades inflation rising
to seven and a half percent economic
growth slowing unemployment rising of
course taxes going up with the next hike
uh and the
uh freeze on a personal allowance on the
income tax and that's in april uh energy
bills uh rising 54 percent to almost 2
000 pounds you know governments uh prime
ministers can get away with quite a lot
i believe in the if the economy is
booming but these headlines are
absolutely right our economy is doing
anything back anything but and and it is
a you know it is a perfect storm it's
going to be uh extremely damaging of
course to boris johnson's premiership
but much more importantly to individual
households yeah i mean all of that
unheard of without actually having the
word recession thrown in there um
annabelle recession in the year ahead
yes or no
no i don't think we're going to see a
recession in the year in the year ahead
simply because of how much the economy
contracted over the course of the
pandemic um of course a lot of the
problems that we're now facing are the
result of a swifter rebound than many
were expecting my big fear is that we're
going to have spiraling inflation i
think that the government has not kept a
lid on the supply the growth of money
supply over the last couple of years and
that's been storing up problems we're
going to have inflation between 5 and 10
until at least 2023 if not beyond and
households are going to feel a real
squeeze
um politically as well it's obviously
very difficult as annabelle said steve
uh the mirror i mean the picture editors
had a good dig for this one haven't they
they're all laughing well rishi shinee
didn't seem to be laughing about this i
think he knows it's as as uh as as
serious as as all the households feel
i can tell you they are far from
laughing because uh you know as
annabelle suggested a prime minister a
chancellor has some political space if
everything seems to be falling apart if
the economy is doing well and people
feel better off um it gives them a bit
of room in a political crisis when
you're in the sort of crisis we were
describing in the first half of this
press preview
and
people are going to be really hit and a
lot of people unused to inflation you
know uh younger people have lived their
lives with out this threat being so
i hate to interrupt you but we're really
running out of time i do apologize we
had so much to back in uh but both of
you stephen annabelle see you soon thank
you both very much